THE SHARK TANK ON THIS THURSDAY
NIGHT.
RANDY HAHN WITH BRET HEDICAN
WE AREREN FRONT.
ONE-TIMER AND HOFER PROBABLY
HASN'T SEEN
BURNS HANDS IT OFF TO EKLUND ON
THE WINGN FRONT!
AND HOFER GOT IT WITH THE BLADE
OF HIS BACD DAHLEN AGAIN
IN FRONT
IT'S EKLUND ON THE REBOUNDTHEY E
UNDER THE BAR.
AND JUST LIKE E  TO EKLUND
WATCHED BY JUSTIN FAULK.
L IN 4:
A SHORTHANDED GOAL FOR LOGAN
COUTURE! SAYS I'M GOING TO
TRY IT
>> Randy: HERE IS A CHANCE FOR .
THIS IS WHAT ENDS UP NET
HERE IS A CHANCE FOR
MERKLEY AND THOSE PLAYS
TYPICALLY DON'T WORK, AS THELEA
GET THROUGH.
RIGHT THERE THE TIP FROM
MERKLEROUGH THE SEAM AGAIN
TO BUCHNEVICH, FOUND THAT BACK
DOOR
AND, WOW,  NIGHT, I AM IN TROUB.
HERE IS SAAD
AND HE SCORES. BODY, KIND OF MAS
YAY STYLE.
THIS IS WHAT HE WAS KNOWN
LOUIS.
BACK TO WALMAN AT THE LINE
HILL A NEAL, AND
IT'S JUST EASYSY
WING FOR THOMAS.
DAHLEN WELL POSITIONED BUT HE
DOESN'T CL
TARASENKO POSITIONED OUT FRONT
MERK BACK AT FULL
STRENGTH WITH NEGATIVE OUT OF
THE AS
HE WILL BURY THIS ONE.
HE IS THE GUY THAT CLEARS IT-3